okay now number two what happens we've
got multiple polynomials and how can we
is there an application of this to
having more than one polygon remain with
you so if I say two polynomial functions
okay if I'm interested in how many
points they intersect that okay so this
is going to be a direct flop on from one
bit okay
to point of view functions cannot
intersect so you got the same cannot
language right and they're parallel
cannot intersect more than n times where
now what's the significance of n you can
actually have the polynomials having
different degrees if you like but n is
going to be is the degree of the higher
polynomial okay so by fire I mean it has
a big a degree okay so if I gave you a
simple example
okay let's say a straight line okay and
a cubic
degree 3 and degree 1 okay there's going
to be at most three points of
intersection which you can actually see
here right there might be less just like
I rub it off if I moved it up again okay
there maybe there stand three points but
it can't be more okay in the same way if
I took a cubic degree three and put it
together with a quadratic case of degree
2 okay in this case the one that I've
drawn again I've got two points of
intersections I could draw one which was
maybe flatter and have three points of
intersection but there's no quadratic I
could draw that won't intersect with the
cubic four times okay cuz it won't match
up with the degree that I've got now can
anyone see why and can you and
particularly connected back to one thing
why is it that if this degree is 3 I can
never get more than 3 points of
intersection with any other graph
polynomials polynomials by definition
polynomial just has the young just has
the one variables we do any other ideas
apart from seeming contradictions of
this okay let me try to explain with an
example okay so let's have two top
polynomials okay let's go with the X
cubed minus x one that I had before okay
and let's see how many times it
intersects with a line like saying one
okay now to find points of intersection
to in two graphs what do we do yeah
that's right you let one equal the other
okay so I'll say P of x equals Q X to
find points of intersection yes thank
you
I'm gonna let P equal Q okay so X cubed
minus X equals 2x plus 1 alright now
what I want to go ahead and solve is him
and usually we take everything over all
into one side so I'm gonna get X cubed
minus 3x minus 1 and then I go ahead and
solve that right oh can you see what's
just happened right in solving a
polynomial with degree 3
we the polynomial degree 1 okay to solve
them the way you do it is you create a
new polynomial with degree 3
namely you got it from here right and of
course if this is degree 3 then from
property 1b I think that's one frame it
can only have a maximum of 3 solutions
only ever give me three solutions and of
course solutions for this thing
what that really needs is points of
intersection okay so you see how one
photos onto two right that's the maximum
number of [ __ ] you're going to get I
have less